est Pressekonferenz zum Bundesvision
Song Contest 2010 mit dabei Adel tavil
wie fast immer ohne Partnerin Annette
Humpe von ich und ich wie eine große
Boulevardzeitung sogar titelte sollen
sie sich getrennt haben doch in der
Online Talkshow klickzoom.de meldet er
sich jetzt mit einem Dementi zurück das
stimmt so nicht also wir machen einfach
eine kreative Pause wir haben seit
2003 sind wir also jetzt 7 Jahre im
Studio eigentlich unentwegt wenn das
erste Album fertig war haben wir direkt
mit dem zweiten begonnen und da ist es
normal nach drei Alben zu sagen okay
jetzt habuen wir nicht direkt ein
zweites noch ein viertes hinterher
sondern lassen uns jetzt mal genug Zeit
um mal auch andere Sachen zu machen und
so ein bisschen ich und ich auch nicht
zu überfordern es läuft auf jeden Fall
sehr gut es macht auch echt Spaß
und also Anette und ich sind eine Herz
und eine Seele also wir haben jetzt hat
jetzt schon wieder sit schon wieder auf
glühenden Kohlen hat schon zwei neue
Songs geschrieben und ich weiß sie wird
mich auch bald wieder anrufen und sagen
ah guck mal ich habe jetzt wieder eine
neue Idee und ähm deswegen also da mache
ich mir überhaupt keine Sorgen wir
genießen die Zeit und man muss auch mal
ein bisschen einen Schritt zurückgehen
um mal zu betrachten was da eigentlich
alles so gelaufen ist die letzten Jahre
es war eine unfassbare Reise ne ja okay
also der Drops ist noch nicht gelutscht
so sieht's
aus